hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show so today I thought I'd take you
through how I'm preparing for my PhD so
just to put a background I will be
starting a PhD in just under a month now
and that will be in medical science at
Cambridge and so also for excited and as
I'm big on science cycle I know that
PhDs can be amazing
they can also be quite stressful and the
fact that I'm already aware this is good
but since I want to make the most out of
my time I just want to make sure that I
can be as prepared as much as possible
really for some reason the crave from of
myself man is coming to me the best-laid
schemes of mice and men often gay wrong
well touch was heavy weights but he
knows the factors that shouldn't even
matter if things go wrong it's about how
you can solve these problems
anyway um if I feel prepared I know
that's the best I can do within the
situation and some more importance but
anyway a PhD is a learning experience
and say I didn't expect to know
everything before I start and I'm
certain to learn various tips and tricks
for at my time there but in this video
I'm gonna go through some different ways
that I am preparing myself because they
might be helpful for you as well I'm so
to help go through this I split this
video into five different sections so
I'll tell you about having the habits
the tools the knowledge the mindset and
the enthusiasm
so first up having the habits so getting
to going into good habits is always
somewhat beneficial and with the number
of experiments replicants conditions
inevitably I'll end up doing being able
to manage this amount in keep track
because of high priority to stay on top
of things and to prevent mistakes and
then all in all just how we have better
faith in what I'm doing
so what happens am I talking about so
firstly labeling so some kind of
systematic labeling procedure will be
really valuable especially when I can
end
the box velvet and offs say having some
kind of ordering naming system and then
backing it up with like an Excel
spreadsheet will probably be a really
good idea secondly I saw that making
figures as you go along is a good thing
to get into the habit of doing and in
addition to this making sure that your
color scheme and fonts is also
consistent begins at the end they're all
formatted in the same way which is
probably a good thing um then folder
eyes say this is why that I thought I
made up but actually it turns out it's
in the urban dictionary so it's a thing
but effectively what I mean is putting
stuff into a folder of it is literally
that simple and I'm not gonna lie it's
been a while since I saw dries and I
kind of kept everything in piles for the
past few years and the problem is I
don't really know how best to do this
and how better
what folders to have so yeah we'll see
how that goes
and the no-brainer is the habit of
writing my lab book with details and
details of details because that's the
only way to track what I'm doing and
also the habits of using a calendar and
filling it out and kind of sticking to
it
because inevitably there's going to be a
lot of things going on and it seems like
the best way to keep on top of it okay
so now we're on to having the tools so
as a kid I used to love stationery
having all like the different pens and
pads of paper but these days
everything's too misty all phones and
tablets and in the cloud so I've watched
a couple of videos and there are some
apps and that's you seem like good apps
to have for a PhD so one that I
recommend or I know I'm going to be
using is mandolin which is just a
reference manager keeps all your
references in one place not that I ever
really use it to read the papers but
it's useful for importing them into
words and when writing up the
dissertation second one is something
called Sado or just any generic PDF
highlighting
ability app so I can make notes about
different papers then we have our studio
which is a way that you can create
graphs with your experimental data then
there is snap gene really handy for
looking at the sequence of your plasmids
and helping you to design primer
sequences and in cleaning stuff then
those illustrator I'm kind of hoping
there'll be some sort of license so that
I can use it for my PhD but I'm it's
good for making figures basically and
figures of high quality as opposed to my
little sketches that you see here and
lastly I put on here graph pad I've
never actually used that look alive
but apparently it's really useful so
yeah if there's any other apps that you
recommend honestly let me know so next
up is having the knowledge so I guess
this is kind of a no-brainer reading
papers connected to my projects
beforehand will probably be a good idea
so yeah of course I've been doing some
of this and I'm just making sure I'm
prepared for when I start but obviously
I'm gonna get the reminder it's reading
fiction other nonfiction books and other
areas of science also gonna be important
but yes having some elements of
knowledge before I start is definitely a
good thing to do okay so next on my list
is having the mindset so some of my best
ideas have literally come from being in
the shower and so along with having
showers taking breaks listen to music I
have tried meditating before didn't
really work out but I might try it again
it's just a good way to stay
distressed and just to relax and open up
your mind to different ideas and
possibilities and you know you gotta
stay positive ask for help if I need it
and always ask for support if I need
just as well and just don't forget the
main reason why I'm doing the PhD in the
first place and so lastly having the
enthusiasm so yeah I am really excited
to start and only time will tell if any
of these preparations will helped me but
nonetheless I am still really excited to
get going and yeah I will probably
somewhat keep you posted and how it goes
as well see I hope some of this was
useful I'm
please interested in how I am preparing
for my PhD and if you have any other
tips be sure to let me know as well
alright thanks for listening